- When we think about our life,
we usually think about
it in a form of a story.
(slow music)
First we were born and
then we did some things
and made some memories and now we're here
and we work at our job or whatever.
But in the future we plan
on doing more things,
seeing the world maybe
and saving up enough money
for a enjoyable retirement.
We all tend to view our lives
in a sort of narrative
structure like this,
with the beginning, a
middle and an eventual end.
Which kinda makes sense because
by reflecting on the past,
it helps us make sense of where we are now
and by having hopes and
dreams for the future,
it gives us something to look forward to,
something to plan towards
and if we currently don't
like our present situation,
we can place our pains and
frustrations on the hope
of a better tomorrow.
But if you think about what it feels like
to actually live life,
like what it feels like
on a day to day basis, it
feels completely different.
We kinda just wake up,
we feel kinda groggy,
we stumble downstairs, get the coffee,
hop in the shower, you
get dressed before getting
in the car to get that bread.
And after you get that bread,
you get more bread at McDonald's
because you have an addiction
and then you come home,
usually pretty tired
and you veg out and watch
Netflix or whatever you do
until you go to bed.
This is what living
life usually feels like
to most people most of the time.
Life in general is usually pretty normal.
You do the things that you do everyday,
you kinda have a routine
or a pattern you stick to
and life usually isn't super
inspiring or mind-blowing,
it's just sort of the
day to day experience.
But is there anything wrong with that?
I mean, social media has us thinking
that everyone's hanging
out on yachts all the time,
going on crazy adventures,
trying out the 2,000 different
bananas in southeast Asia
and everyone's getting married
to the person of their dreams,
popping out the most beautiful babies.
But that's not life,
that's a highlight reel.
And these highlights
that we constantly absorb
by the people we follow on
Instagram or the movies we watch
on Netflix, these highlights start
to really influence the
story we tell ourselves
about our own lives.
We start viewing our
lives, at least our lives
lived to it's fullest potential
as a life with as many of these highlights
in it as possible, so the
days when these awesome,
crazy things aren't happening,
we view that as somehow suboptimal.
Our amazing days become the expectation
and our normal days become
boring, like we're wasting
our potential, we're
wasting our lives away.
But this story we tell
ourselves, this adventure life,
no one's life is like this,
not Dwayne Johnson, not Elon Musk.
Sure, these guys are
doing some really cool,
important things more often than we are
but still the majority of their lives,
they just sort of wake up,
they do a bunch of things
they don't wanna do,
they're grinding it out,
they're working hard, they're
often really frustrated
or stressed out.
They still poop, they still have to eat.
Most of their lives exist
in this sort of day to day monotony.
They're experiencing life
in the exact same way that you are,
except when Elon Musk is fantasizing
about escaping the day to day
grind and taking a vacation,
instead of the Bahamas,
he's thinking Mars.
Assuming you get eight
hours of sleep every night,
which I'm sure you do, you only
have about 16 hours to live
because you only experience
life one day at a time.
That little section of time
between lifting your head
off the pillow and
putting it back down again
and all that stuff in between
that seems kind of normal
and kinda inconsequential,
that's all life is,
it's just that thing over
and over and over again.
And this can sound super
depressing or super inspiring,
depending on how you look at it.
It can be depressing,
obviously if you don't like
those 16 hours, usually,
a lot of us are slaves
to our bad habits.
We do things we don't want to do.
We work jobs we don't really like
and we're put in certain
financial or social situations
that we really don't like being in.
So every single day, day after day
is something we generally
don't like doing.
Which is why we fantasize
about the future so much.
We're still waiting to live our real lives
and if this is all there is,
then that's obviously super depressing.
But there's a silver lining
because changing your entire life
isn't as big of a feat
as you might think it is.
Since life is lived in
these little 16 hour
little mini episodes, that's
a very manageable amount
of time to perfect.
We can start to build habits
that we actually enjoy doing
and that are good for us
and we can train ourselves to make choices
that are actually aligned with our values
and will help us be the person
we want to be every single day.
Because a good life is just
a serious of good days,
not necessarily days where
everything went our way
and nothing was difficult or stressful
but days where our system was running.
We gave life a good shot, we
made choices that are aligned
with our values and we
did the little things
that make us happy.
Maybe that's having a good
conversation with a friend
or putting a little extra
effort into cooking,
so you eat something kinda memorable
and that you're proud of,
maybe that's developing one
positive habit at a time
so that the things that
keep you grounded and happy
and your mood elevated,
start to become things
that you do automatically.
Viewing life on a micro scale like this
also adds clarity to the little choices
we make throughout the day.
If you've always wanted to
be a more social person,
then that means saying yes
to beers with the boys today,
when you get the invitation.
And if you're constantly fantasizing
about being a more fit person,
that means going to the gym today.
Because your life is
today, that's all it is.
It's just today repeated.
A big thank you to Skillshare
for sponsoring this video.
One problem you might encounter
when trying to start a new habit
is that when you try to go from something
like watching YouTube videos
obsessively every single day
to trying to replace that
habit with reading a book,
you're going from something
that's super stimulating
to something that's a lot
slower paced and harder to do.
So the transition can be pretty jarring
and you might quit right
away, unfortunately.
A great way to counteract this problem
is to take smaller steps,
so go from something super
stimulating, like watching videos
to watching just better videos.
A great example of this is to
utilize today's video sponsor,
Skillshare, which is an
online learning platform
with thousands of classes
covering dozens of topics
that'll help you learn real world skills
and just make you smarter in general.
Simon Sinek even has a class on Skillshare
where he teaches you about how
to give better presentations
which is the class I'm
currently diving into.
Skillshare is offering better
idea viewers two months
of Skillshare premium absolutely free
which means that right now
when you click the link
in the description, you have access
to every single class on Skillshare,
including Simon Sinek's
awesome presentation class
and after your free trial expires,
Skillshare is still super affordable.
If you choose their annual membership,
the monthly hit is less than $10 a month.
So kind of a no brainer,
so click that link below
and get access to the thousands of classes
that are on Skillshare, expand your mind,
make yourself smarter
and have a great time.
If you like this video,
make sure to hit like,
'cause when you hit like, the algorithm
does fancy things and my bald head appears
in people's homepages and if
they're struggling through life
or there's something they wanna work on,
sometimes my videos motivate
them to make a positive change.
So it's kinda win-win for everybody.
If you're lurking here and
this is the millionth time
you've seen my face or
seen one of my videos,
what are you doing, just
hit that subscribe button
and hit the bell icon so that
you don't miss future videos.
You'll actually get notified
and be part of the notification army.
Also I just relaunched my Instagram.
The minute we hit 10,000 followers
is the minute I give away
a whole bunch of Kindles
so that you guys have absolutely no excuse
not to read the books I recommend.
So hit the link in the description,
follow me on Instagram.
I know this is kinda ironic
because I just said, oh
we're influenced by Instagram
and all these people on yachts and stuff,
but I can assure you, I'm almost,
actually I've never been on a yacht
and I live a really normally life.
So delete all those travel pages,
unfollow them, follow me instead
because I'll probably make you feel
really good about your life.
Yeah, other than that,
thank you for watching
and we'll catch you in the next video.